you ever get I don't know did you ever
see them in concert Queen no I wish
die-hard fan best frontman to me ever
I think the the rare breed of both the
frontman and music and musician wrapped
up into one and I don't there's nobody
that rivals that to me
I completely agree do you have a
favorite album no I'm actually partial
to two live albums I know what's your
first makes every producer I'm sure goes
oh come on what we spent you know
because I love hearing it raw I love in
Montreal I loved his eleven mature dope
totally again I could talk the whole
interview about Bowie I really could but
yeah so what first of all I want to
start by saying you were great in the
movie thank you um what the hell is it
like when you [ __ ] you're reading the
script and you're like and I'm gonna
have fight scenes with Jason right well
I think truthfully when that happens you
go okay I want to and then I look at the
picture of ocean master I go okay I want
to I want to gain some weight I want to
spend I'm not good I didn't take a job
from whatever was say December to April
we started shooting and spent that whole
time training eating and doing that five
times a week so I could get into shape
so I could be a formidable opponent I
mean I'm not gonna all of a sudden grow
four inches but but that's okay you know
rarely do I had six feet feel like a
real small guy but you know when you're
staying next to us somebody's about six
for you you do so I just want to be in
the best shape that I could one of the
things and it's fake so that helps one
of the things about this is the recent
DC films have been a little bit darker
and this is like bright and colorful and
totally different yeah can you sort of
talk about that well I think I think
James takes James Wan takes the lead
from the comic I think the comic is very
bright when you have a character that is
typically orange and green and
underwater III think there's a certain
amount of fun and tongue-in-cheek that
you have to have with it and I think he
embraced that I
think there that's that's vital to his
character to Aquaman's character so
while he doesn't belong and this is
certainly a meaning in either world and
that's part of his hero's journey is
becoming sort of joining these two
worlds even by default it's I think it
was incredibly important to take a big
leap and have it be bright and and
vibrant I think that's that's kind of
paramount to to to the comic before I
run out of time with you I want to
switch and ask something else which is
did you ever think when you signed on to
play Ed Warren that it was going to lead
to this massive franchise with all these
movies and of course what can you tease
about the upcoming spinoff I mean I
think yeah we we just finished Annabelle
three and we'll shoot conjuring three in
the spring I did I think I I never think
of it in terms of numbers I did know
this was coming from James's mouth that
if we got it right there would be
several movies I don't think nobody
anticipated all the spin-offs I thought
I'd be just more conjuring movies I
didn't even think about the villains of
the series going out for getting their
owns I think that was just a happy
accident that they have cast certainly
capitalized on yeah but I I mean listen
I trust that guy if you can't tell after
five movies then he said to me yeah I
know he said if we get it right there'll
be several of these and I have such a
fun time playing the role in playing
with Vieira that I'll I'll do that as
long as as long as they work
you